man a lot of you feel that you know
something about binary so I thought this
is a relatively simple and compact topic
that I might be able to make a
relatively short video about I want to
start off by just doing a simple
addition some in the normal tens
counting system that we use just to
remind you about things like how to
carry a digit from one column into the
column to the left of it and so on
first thing I probably ought to do right
up at the top here which is why I've
tried to leave myself a bit of space is
to remind you what do these columns mean
in this column is the unit's
always it's the ones if you like and in
the tens system the one to the left of
it is counting up the number of tens
that you've got and of course this one
on the left is counting up the hundreds
the more you get into the mathematics of
this the more you learn that really and
more fundamentally hundred is 10 to the
power 2 10 itself is a ten to the power
one call if we have thousands over here
that's the 10 to the power 3 column so
what's this one well anything to the
power 0 is 1 even 2 or 3 or 77 anything
to the power 0 is 1 okay so those
headings I hope will remind you about
what each column actually means now
let's just draw a line here and do this
addition 5 Plus 5 is 10 but if you get
10 in any one of these columns you can't
write down 10 the rule is it's every
digit in one of these columns can range
between 0 and 9 when we come on to
binary of course we'll be counting in
twos and the rule there is every digit
you put down must be 0 or 1 but it can't
be two so instead of saying five plus
five is ten and writing ten if you
recall we put down a nought and we carry
a 1 you make a little note of it somehow
down here and then what you do is you
say well in the tens column I've got
five tens in this certain number up here
three tens in this one five and three is
eight eight in the tens column are but I
carried one over from
here so that's a total of nine tens
there's nothing further to carry out
from the tens column into the hundreds
because it's in range it's got a nine so
all you do is put a 1 there nothing
there
1 plus nothing is 1 so the answer is 190
let's do a binary example immediately
below this decimal one so we're going to
be in 4-bit binary from here on in down
here so straight away by analogy with
what's gone on above we can say the
first column on the left will be 2 to
the power zeros then will be 2 to the
power 1 then we'll have 2 to the power 2
and then we'll have 2 to the power 3 1 2
3 4 bits or if you like you can also
make a note to yourself that 2 to the
power 3 this is the 8th column 2 squared
this is the fourth column this is the
twos column and recalling that anything
to the power 0 is 1 this is the ones or
the unit's column is going to come on
down here let's do the following binary
addition 1 0 1 1 plus 0 0 1 1 so this
first number we put in here is 11 in
decimal notation the one in the row
below it that we're going to add on no
eight no fours 1 2 or 1 1 2 + 1 is 3 so
what we're doing in binary is we're
going to add 11 to 3 and we hope that
the binary answer will look like 14 in
binary but again let me emphasize that
the business about carrying digits
across applies with just the same
ferocity in binary as it does in decimal
so this is what you do you start off
always on the right-hand column 1 plus 1
is 2
you want to write down 2 but you're not
allowed to it's like saying 5 Plus 5 is
10 you can't write 10 you've got to
write zero down and carry one just the
same here 1 plus 1 is 2 but I have to
zero down and carry one as a memo to say
I must remember to add that one in as
well now this gets really hairy now
you've got 1 plus 1 plus 1 which is 3
now if you're not allowed to write down
a 2 as an answer in this column you're
absolutely not allowed to write down 3
so how do you cope with this situation
you cope with it by saying well the 3
that has a mast itself in this column is
actually composed of a 2 plus a 1 in
this column so the one left over you
write down here
but that 2 now carries across as a carry
into the next column on the left and now
find myself with 0 0 & 1 well that's
easy that's just 1 in total finally 1
plus 0 dead easy so that's the end of
that addition you end up with an answer
that's got one in the age column we've
got a four we've got a two 8 + 4 is 12 +
2 is 14 that's the right answer
now those of you who are desperately
keen computer file types will know from
doctor heart bleeds
why Gangnam style throat YouTube because
it got 2 billion hits the problem with
that is it overflows a 32-bit integer
what does it mean to say you were
overflowing an n-bit representation
well I can show that very easily just
what happens with the biggest
representation that you can get in 4
bits which is an 8 plus a 4 plus a 2
plus a 1 which of course is 15 what
happens if you add 1 to that well it
overflows why because you do 1 plus 1 is
0 carry 1 1 plus that 1 is 0 and carry 1
1 plus 1 is 0 and carry a 1 again 1 plus
1 is 0 and carry 1
errr we've run out of space we had a
carry out as it's called from the fourth
column across into the 5th column from
the right so we had a carry out into a
situation a column that didn't exist and
carries in two columns that exists as
we've seen you just
I'm up and take account of them but if
you have a carry out into an adjacent
Kanta left that doesn't exist
that's called an overflow and you've got
to be constantly aware that overflows
can occur it still prompts the question
that if we did want to do negative
numbers within a 4-bit constrained
how could we do actually free software
is a wonderful place to do that kind of
work